los problemas en donde usamos la
ecuación del espejo pueden ser
intimidantes las primeras veces que los
resolvemos pero esto no es porque la
ecuación sea muy difícil de hecho es
bastante fácil solo hay que sumar
algunas fracciones pero la parte que nos
confunde es decidir si estas deben ser
positivas o negativas hay muchas
decisiones que tomar para asignar si
unos positivos o negativos y con que nos
equivoquemos en uno solo de éstos
tendremos la respuesta incorrecta así
que vamos a resolver unos cuantos
problemas usando la ecuación del espejo
para que vean como asignamos los signos
ahora debo advertirles que cada quien
tiene su convención para asignar signos
hay muchas convenciones de signos cuando
trabajamos con óptica la que vamos a
usar aquí es la que yo considero es la
más común en los libros de texto y es
aquella que dice que todo lo que se
encuentre por delante del espejo y para
saber a dónde es adelante vamos a poner
nuestro ojo por acá estamos viendo a un
objeto que puede ser un póster o una
flecha está
cosa azul de aquí y lo tenemos enfrente
de este espejo de aquí y la convención
que estoy usando es que todo lo que se
encuentre de este lado del espejo se va
a considerar positivo así que si tenemos
un punto focal de este lado será
positivo si tenemos la distancia a un
objeto de este lado esa distancia será
positiva y si la distancia a la imagen
también resulta positiva sabremos que se
encontrará de este lado del espejo todo
lo que sea negativo por ejemplo si
obtenemos una distancia a la imagen
negativa después de hacer nuestros
cálculos sabremos que esto quedó atrás
del espejo y así como que tiene sentido
todo lo que sea negativo va a estar
atrás todo lo que esté positivo va a
estar adelante así que este lado de aquí
será enfrente del espejo y todo será
positivo y en este lado de aquí será
atrás del espejo y todo será negativo
aquí en este problema ya tenemos algunos
números así que vamos a resolver el
problema que tenemos que hacer usamos la
ecuación del espejo y decimos que 1
entre el punto focal y aquí tenemos que
decidir si esto es un número positivo o
negativo y este espejo conforme lo vemos
aquí tiene una forma cóncava es un
espejo cóncavo y la convención de los
signos que acabamos de discutir y los
signos que usamos en esta fórmula es que
los espejos cóncavos siempre van a tener
un punto focal positivo en otras
palabras ya que este punto focal se
encuentra a 4 centímetros a partir del
centro del espejo y está enfrente pues
voy a poner aquí cuatro centímetros
positivos noten que no estoy haciendo
ninguna conversión está bien si ustedes
quieren dejar aquí centímetros como
unidades siempre y cuando todas las
unidades sean las mismas si ponen todo
en centímetros su resultado también
estará en centímetros vamos a decir que
esto es igual a 1 entre la distancia al
objeto y otra advertencia a veces en
lugar de encontrarse esto como de
subíndice o pueden encontrar esto como
ese subíndice o como la distancia al
objeto
encontrarse de la distancia a la imagen
como ese y son lo mismo solo que usan
letras diferentes la distancia al objeto
nuevamente se encuentra de este lado
enfrente del espejo por lo que será una
cantidad positiva será de 12 centímetros
positivos 12 metros que se miden desde
el centro del espejo así que aquí
también tenemos 12 centímetros positivos
y esto le sumamos 1 entre la distancia a
la imagen aquí no conocemos cuál es la
distancia a la imagen no la he dibujado
así que la desconocemos va a ser una
sorpresa y la vamos a despejar para
hacerlo resto 1 entre 12 positivo en
ambos lados de la igualdad lo que nos da
1 entre cuatro centímetros positivo
menos uno entre 12 centímetros positivo
y esto va a tener que ser igual a 1
entre la distancia la imagen un cuarto
lo podemos reescribir como 312 abós así
que 32 seamos menos un doceavo va a ser
igual a 212 a 2
y esto va a ser igual a 1 / la distancia
a la imagen pero 2 doceavos es igual a
un sexto así que uno entre la distancia
a la imagen es igual a un sexto pero
recuerden que no queremos el inverso de
la distancia a la imagen
queremos conocer la distancia a la
imagen y a veces las personas se les
olvida invertir esto así que sacamos el
inverso en cada lado de la igualdad y
nos queda que la distancia a la imagen
va a ser igual a 6 centímetros resultó
un valor positivo y esto es importante
seis centímetros positivos así que dónde
va a estar nuestra imagen como esta
distancia resultó ser positiva en la
imagen va a estar en frente del espejo
así que va a estar a seis centímetros
por enfrente del espejo más o menos por
acá
así que en este punto de acá es donde
estará nuestra imagen pero no sabemos
qué tan grande va a ser o si va a estar
derecha o invertida para encontrar esto
necesitamos usar una ecuación diferente
y a esta ecuación la conocemos como la
ecuación del aumento a la que
representamos con la letra m mayúscula
así que el aumento va a ser igual a la
altura de la imagen dividida entre la
altura del objeto y esto va a ser igual
a menos la distancia a la imagen
dividida entre la distancia al objeto
así que resulta que esta proporción
negativa entre la distancia de la imagen
y la distancia del objeto siempre es
igual a la proporción de la altura de la
imagen entre la altura del objeto así
que cuál será la altura de nuestra
imagen pues vamos a despejar la la
altura de la imagen va a ser igual
multiplicamos ambos lados de la igualdad
por la altura del objeto aquí ya está el
lado negativo así que es menos la altura
del objeto multiplicado por la
proporción de la distancia a la imagen
entre la distancia
ahora sustituimos los números la altura
del objeto es de aquí nos dice que es de
3 centímetros así que escribimos menos
tres centímetros multiplicado por la
proporción de la distancia a la imagen
que es de 6 centímetros positivos entre
la distancia del objeto que es de 12
centímetros si resolvemos esto nos queda
un medio x menos 3 que es menos 1.5
centímetros en este caso el signo
negativo nos indica que la imagen está
invertida es decir la vamos a ver de
cabeza comparada con el objeto original
y el 1.5 es que tan alta va a ser así
que nos queda una imagen que va a estar
a 6 centímetros
en frente del espejo va a tener una
altura que es la mitad del original 1.5
centímetros y va a estar de cabeza ya
que el resultado nos dio un signo
negativo esto es lo que veremos al
observar en este espejo imagínense que
es un espejo de las casas de la risa
está medio raro veremos una imagen
invertida
y que nos daría la impresión de poder
agarrar pero es solamente una ilusión
óptica no tendremos un objeto allá
solamente es la imagen de este otro
objeto este fue un ejemplo usando un
espejo cóncavo que cambiaría si ahora en
lugar de tener nuestro objeto aquí lo
pusiéramos por acá así que en lugar de
estar a 12 centímetros ahora estaría a 3
centímetros de distancia del centro del
espejo que veríamos diferente todo
quedaría igual a excepción de la
distancia al objeto aquí en lugar de
tener 12 centímetros positivos
tendríamos tres centímetros positivos
por lo que la ecuación del espejo
funciona exactamente igual aquí ponemos
la distancia que sea la que tenga el
objeto despejamos nuestra distancia la
imagen y en este caso vamos a tener una
distancia a la imagen diferente pero no
importa cual sea nos va a indicar en
donde se encuentra la imagen y ahora
tomaremos esta distancia a la imagen y
la usaremos en nuestra ecuación del
aumento
si es que queremos conocer qué tan alta
va a ser esta imagen y si estará derecha
o estará de cabeza así que estos números
serán diferentes pero vamos a usar
nuestras ecuaciones de la misma manera y
ahora qué pasaría si en lugar de usar un
espejo cóncavo usáramos un espejo
convexo digamos que ahora nuestro espejo
tiene esta forma imaginen que nuestro
ojo se encuentra nuevamente por acá
observando a este objeto dentro del
espejo y vamos a ver la imagen del
objeto veremos al objeto que está aquí y
además veremos su imagen este espejo en
lugar de ser cóncavo va a ser convexo
así que la distancia focal se va a
encontrar atrás del espejo y ahora qué
hacemos para encontrar en dónde va a
estar la imagen pues nuevamente usamos
la ecuación del espejo 1 entre la
distancia focal y nuevamente en este
instante tengo que decidir cuál será el
signo que tenga esta distancia focal con
la convención que estamos usando la
distancia focal 50
atrás del espejo así que la distancia
focal para este espejo convexo va a ser
negativa aquí tenemos menos cuatro
centímetros esto va a ser igual a 1
entre la distancia al objeto aquí
nuevamente el objeto se encuentra
enfrente del espejo a 12 centímetros por
lo que esta distancia va a ser de 12
centímetros positivos y a esto le
agregamos el inverso de la distancia de
la imagen que es nuestra incógnita y lo
que queremos encontrar así que en este
caso tenemos 1 entre menos 4 y
nuevamente tenemos que restar 1 entre 12
positivo y esto va a ser igual a 1 entre
la distancia a la imagen de manera que
ahora en el lado izquierdo nos queda 1
entre menos 4 pero esto es igual a menos
3 12 ambos menos 3 doceavos menos un
doceavo nos va a dar menos 412 ambos y
esto es igual a 1 entre la distancia de
la imagen pero menos 4 doceavos es lo
mismo que menos un tercio por lo
1 / la distancia a la imagen es igual a
menos un tercio y si invertimos ambos
términos nos queda que la distancia a la
imagen será de menos tres centímetros en
otras palabras esto es igual a menos un
tercio de manera que cuando lo
invertimos nos queda que la distancia de
la imagen es de menos tres centímetros
en donde va a estar esta imagen
bueno pues vemos que tiene el signo
negativo por lo que va a quedar atrás
del espejo ya que esta es la convención
de signos que usamos así que estará a
tres centímetros atrás del espejo más o
menos por acá tres centímetros atrás del
espejo y de nuevo si queremos conocer
qué tan alta va a ser esta imagen y si
va a estar derecha o de cabeza tenemos
que usar la fórmula del aumento
recordamos que esta ecuación del aumento
luce así la proporción de la altura de
la imagen entre la altura del objeto va
a ser igual al negativo de la proporción
de la distancia a la imagen entre la
distancia del objeto
veamos a que será igual este lado
derecho es el negativo de menos 3 que es
la distancia al objeto así que aquí
ponemos el menos 3 tenemos este negativo
de siempre aquí y además tenemos esta
cantidad negativa aquí arriba que
ponemos entre paréntesis para no
confundirnos esto entre la distancia a
la imagen que es de 12 centímetros
positivos nos queda el negativo de menos
3 entre 12 lo que nos da 3 positivo
entre 12 un cuarto positivo los
centímetros se cancelan y lo que nos
dice esta proporción que es el aumento
pues nos dice que la imagen no va a
estar invertida ya que nos dio positivo
y la proporción de un cuarto nos dirá
que es un cuarto de la altura del objeto
original y la razón de esto es que esta
proporción es igual a la altura de la
imagen entre la altura del objeto en
otras palabras si multiplico ambos lados
por la altura del objeto me va a quedar
que la altura de la imagen es igual a un
cuarto positivo por la altura del objeto
la altura de nuestro objeto es de 3
centímetros por lo que la altura de la
imagen es una cuarta parte de esto pero
no importa cuál sea la altura del objeto
la vamos a multiplicar por esta
proporción de menos de entre 2 y nos
dará la altura de la imagen por lo que
aquí nos queda tres cuartos de
centímetros positivos por lo que va a
ser una imagen muy pequeñita una imagen
pequeñita que va a estar derecha va a
estar por acá y va a ser pequeñita con
una altura de tres cuartos de
centímetros en resumen podemos usar la
ecuación del espejo para saber en dónde
se va a encontrar la imagen la
convención de signos que estamos usando
es que los objetos y distancias focales
que se encuentran por delante del espejo
van a ser positivas y todo lo que se
encuentre por atrás del espejo va a ser
negativo
usar la ecuación del aumento para
encontrar la altura de la imagen con
respecto a la altura del objeto al tomar
el negativo de la distancia a la imagen
y dividirla entre la distancia del
objeto